everyone loves the Scottish Princess
Merida from brave but the secret history
of Merida is a lot crazier than the
movie stay tuned to find out all about
the real world of brave in 2012 Pixar
studios released their first ever Disney
princess movie brave was a huge deal
because it Asher din a new era for
princesses Merida is still the only
princess from the Pixar studios he can't
understand her she's from the other
studio and the fiery redhead is a
princess to be admired Merida was the
first princess to come from a completely
original story every other princess was
based on either a fairy tale or a
historical figure Mulan and Pocahontas
are the historical princesses but all
the rest are based on stories only one
of their princess can claim the original
story title and that's Moana but Merida
was definitely the first brave is also
different from other Disney Princess
movies in a lot of different ways first
of all both of Meredith parents are
alive thanks Pixar seriously what is up
with all the lost parents and Disney
movies it's pretty much a joke at this
point well it's a really sad joke anyway
after all the classic princesses like
Cinderella and Aurora Disney started
giving us princesses who didn't quite
fit in the 90s had a lot of independent
princesses who did not need to be saved
by a man it makes sense because the
1990s was an era of girl power it's
pretty cool that Mulan saved all of
China by herself you know but there was
always a romantic tale not in brave
Merida was the first princess to not
have a love story Meredith does not want
to get married they originally were
going to give her a love interest but
they decided Merida was just too
independent for that and it was really
refreshing not everyone needs a love
story for a happy ending Moana followed
this path the brave was the first the
plot in case it's been a while since
you've watched brave we're going to do a
quick refresher but we're pretty sure
you'll want to re-watch it after this
video the movie starts of Princess
Merida sixth birthday she is out for a
picnic with her parents King Fergus and
Queen Eleanor Fergus gives Merida her
first bow and arrow and Merida is a
natural she fires off an arrow into the
woods where she sees magic blue lights
called willow the wisp while she's off
following the magic her parents and
their men get attacked by a big scare
named more dude Eleanor Russia's Merida
to safety 10 years later we find out
that Fergus lost his leg two more do
that could have been way more tragic for
Fergus is hilarious
so Ursula I had all of you lost was his
leg Merida also has triplet little
brothers who are constantly up to
trouble
Eleanor wants Merida to be a proper lady
but Merida just wants to do her own
thing she is definitely not your typical
princess and this causes a bunch of
issues between Merida and her mom three
Lords arrived to give their firstborn
sons in marriage to Merida
but she is not having it she chooses
archery as their test and then she
competes for her own hand get it girl
Merida and Eleanor get Anik huge fight
Merida runs off on her horse into the
woods and sees the will-o'-the-wisps
again the magic lights are supposed to
lead you to her fate can we get some
Will O the wisps up in here please the
lights take Merida to the home of a
witch Merida asks for a spell that will
change her mother which she thinks will
change her fate of marriage
unfortunately the spell changes her
mother a little too much Eleanor turns
into a giant bear Fergus thinks that the
bear is mordioux and tries to attack it
Merida has to take her mother to safety
they bond as mother bear and daughter
but Eleanor is turning into a real bear
Merida learns this has happened before
and more do is actually a cursed King
with her mom's help Merida helps unite
all the fighting Lords with her father's
army there's a big fight and mordioux
meets his end Merida apologizes to her
mother and Eleanor turns back into a
human Merida doesn't have to get married
and the different clans are united
choosing your own destiny is important
we love that message the history of
brave okay it's safe to assume no one
was getting turned into giant bears in
ancient Scotland but what was really
going on in the country above England
Scotland has a long and often violent
history but Meredith's fiery spirit and
belief in choosing her own destiny as a
super Scottish attitude brave really
captures the fierce spirit of the Scots
I would eat
lives within us according to Disney
brave takes place in the 10th century
Scotland
that's the 900s so it was over a
thousand years ago that also makes
Merida one of the oldest Disney
Princesses this time period was known as
the High Middle Ages and in Far North
Europe it was known as the Viking Age
Vikings can we get a brave and how to
train your dragon mash up that would be
epic one of the coolest things about
Scottish history is that they managed to
keep the Romans from invading the
ancient Romans conquered everyone and
they took over almost all of England
they tried really hard to take over
Scotland or Caledonia but they were no
match for the fierce warriors of the pyx
the pics are awesome they would tattoo
their skin with all sorts of designs and
blue ink they looked really intimidating
to their enemies and boy could they
fight the fakes didn't have a bunch of
impressive technology like the Romans
but they were one of the only groups in
the world to beat them
the Scottish pride started really early
Merida and Fergus definitely got some of
that spunkiness the pics were one of the
main kingdoms in Scotland at this time
but there were several other kingdoms
there were the angles the Britons and
the gales along with some smaller
kingdoms many of these were united into
the Pictish Kingdom but then they faced
lots of raids from the Vikings the
Vikings managed to take control of a
bunch of the northern and western
islands and then there was a lot of
fighting on the mainland many of the
people in Scotland had converted to
Christianity but the Vikings worshipped
Norse gods this caused even more bloody
conflict in the year 900 a guy named
Constantine makkad became king of the
Picts and he took a totally different
approach to deal with the Vikings
instead of violence Constantine used
diplomacy at that time that mostly men
to marrying off his daughters to Viking
war leaders hey why didn't his daughters
get any say in this well unfortunately
women didn't really have any rights
especially princesses marriage for love
was unheard of among Royals marriage was
used to strengthen alliances that seems
really messed up these days but that is
the way it was of course that is why
Merida is such a great friend to us and
why we love her story all of the clans
under her father's rule hated each other
and Merida was expected to marry one of
the
to make sure there was peace its
marriage it's not the end of the world
eleanor was probably married off to
Fergus for the same reason but they
definitely seemed to love each other
we're glad we don't have to marry to
prevent war anymore
Constantine's dad Kenneth MacAlpin was
the first real King he United many of
the Gaels
and the picks the constatine took it a
step further then we have to deal with a
guy with a really strange name ethel
stan was an early king of the
anglo-saxons which was the group of
people in England after the Vikings were
more or less defeated Athelstan gets it
in his head that he can take over
Scotland weird flex but Oh gay this dude
needs some history lessons trying to
take over Scotland never ends well
Constantine and his armies whole ah that
doughnut our castle this castle is epic
it looks like something straight out of
a fairy tale
or maybe Game of Thrones it's high up on
a cliff over the sea and it's really
hard to attack Ethel Stan tries his best
to seize dunnottar castle but the Scots
are too strong and too well defended at
the stan lost but constatine was mad he
decides to try to take over England in
retaliation hey what happened to
diplomacy he must have been out of
daughters to marry off Konstantin called
on all his allies the armies of the
Britons the angles and the Vikings
joined him for war Constantine was
defeated but he put up a pretty good
fight
Ethel Stan gave up on trying to invade
Scotland those Scots were just too
fierce King Fergus Merida's goofy but
tough dad was not a real person and
Fergus is a really common name in
Scottish history but it is totally
possible that some of the inspiration
for the King and brave came from a real
King Fergus he didn't live in the 10th
century when the movie takes place and
he wasn't really a King Fergus of
Galloway lived in the 1100s Galloway is
a small region of Scotland and it's
likely that he was just the leader of
the most powerful family in that region
he had three sons
just like the Fergus from brave he
formed a marshall alliance with the
country that is now ireland and he did
try to take over some land in southern
scotland but overall he wasn't a bad guy
he set up a bunch of churches and
monasteries he had managed to resist
Scotland rule for a long time but he
eventually was defeated there is also
some specular
that one of King Arthur's knights was
actually based on Fergus of Galloway the
tartan Merida and her family are part of
a fictional plan dun broch they wear a
green tartan a tartan is a plat fabric
that Scottish people used to represent
their clans or families not only is the
dun broch clan made up but the tartan
and brave is impossible to make in real
life Tartans were born by Scottish
people for centuries but they were bands
for a while in the 1700s when Scotland
became part of England the English
Parliament's tried to ban all the
important parts of Scottish culture but
Tartans made a comeback in 1822
by then a lot of the Weaver's and
original patterns were lost so clans how
to create new tartan patterns it's
almost not clear if Tartans were worn
before at the 1500s but if Eleanor and
Merida were will they probably would
have not worn the same tartan women
typically wore dress Tartans which had a
white background and lighter patterns do
any of you of Scottish heritage know
what your family's tartan looks like not
quite historic although the Disney wiki
says brave takes place in the 10th
century there are several historically
wrong things in the movie first of all
bears were likely extinct in Scotland
way before the movie they eat haggis a
traditional Scottish meal made in a
sheep stomach but haggis was not around
for another few hundred years the style
of Meredith's dress and the bagpipes
date to the 1300s and then there are the
clan wars
although clans likely fought each other
early on the clan feuds in brave sound a
lot like the clan feuds of later times
during the 10th century the bottles were
largely against Vikings or other ethnic
groups not individual clans the first
real clan war that is documented didn't
occur until thirteen forty and it lasted
140 years
this was also happening during the Wars
of Independence when Scotland was trying
to resist English rule which they
managed to do for a few hundred years
the clan wars that occurred throughout
Scottish history were incredibly violent
and when these clans fought amongst
themselves it was hard to fight off the
English eventually Scotland did become
part of Great Britain although they
maintained some independent rights this
streak of
dependence is an amazing trait of
Scottish people throughout history and
we think our favorite Scottish princess
captured this fierceness and
independence perfectly brave might not
be the most popular Disney movie but
it's definitely one of the most
interesting Merida is one of the coolest
princesses because she's a fighter and
doesn't need a man she's a totally
original character and the history
behind brave is so interesting it was a
lot more violent than just fighting off
a magic bear but it is a Disney movie
after all what is your favorite part of
brave sound off in the comments section
and that's the bloody second at history
behind brave be sure to like this video
and click that big red subscribe button
see you next time
[Music]